citizens of the reject Nation we are
here to watch Reacher penultimate
episode episode 7. it's been like three
days since we've seen the last episode
of Reacher so I don't remember what
happened in last week's episode
hopefully I can recall in just enough
time guys leave a like on this video
reach for that like button reach for
that subscribe and notification Bell
button to get notified when our reaction
the finale is up reach for our patreon
and become a super sexy reject by doing
full-length Reaction watch the longest
sync up with your own copy of Reacher we
also cover several things over there
exclusively reaction highlights and
watch songs included reach for Jordan
I got it got me
not funny enough John not funny enough
I'll work on a second one for them they
rely on Comedy gold here that's true
Jack teacher alrighty guys let's do it
[Music]
still no leads not useful stuff we're
being told to chase down don't feel like
the way to go you talk to Finley about
it are you shutting me down I forgot you
were in the show I
tried calling Paul again today
Charlie too they're dead they ain't
gonna answer and they're in the wind
I've been thinking maybe we should leave
even if y'all solve this with Mr Cleaner
did I'm afraid this town will just go
right back to the way it was before he
came here you think they're about to die
it must be he's sympathetic now
oh it's too bad John we don't need to
make jokes every five seconds according
to a couple of comments that really
don't like us but apparently I've been
sticking around this whole time yeah
just to make sure we're still making
those inappropriate jokes I appreciate
it duly noted any serious commentary
I don't find it funny because we don't
make jokes anymore
nice t-shirt
[Music]
what a memory trigger die though
airport must be hotbed I'm going to tell
you something that won't make much sense
now but hopefully it will one day the
world [__] sucks Joe you don't need
to solve all the world's problems
solving some is more than enough and
richer you have the strength of three
boys your age what will you do with that
strength get more strength
wow that rolling backpack triggered all
that yep
Ink's easy to get plates are doable
acquiring the right currency paper well
there was only one place in the country
that made the paper and Joe had it
locked down like Sing Sing unless he
didn't unless he didn't unless he didn't
anything else ran into another one I was
Venezuelan guys what happened we played
hangman what word did he guess Hubble
was a currency manager Delton Hard Cash
he could have been working with somebody
the supplier who was compromised take me
to the body shop gotta pick up the
Bentley I need to make a stop first he
had a town full of them quick stop at a
funeral those who walk uprightly
enter into peace
when I die John I want my ashes
scattered across the nearest local
Denny's yes I can I can do that for you
with bad bikes playing back of pipes
what you think you're doing paying my
respects I think you'll kill me don't
you like that I sliced you up just like
you sliced him
thumbnail
what you meant a lot to the people of
this town so I'm paying my respects to
margrave as his chief detective dick
step back Son Well there would be two
kliners in that grave
instead of threat did Roscoe check in
with you lately no but I should hear
from a card later today oh no man I'm
worried about the card I ain't got but
two of them windows tinted yet good
enough you want to take it half done
only rock stars need 14 in Windows I'll
pay full price Tim get some kitty litter
on that oil spill Tim
yeah are you sure how comfortable
spending a count of the world you want
me to buy you something how about some
jeans and tickets to a Hall and Oates
concert
sounds nice
that's a great response
what is Tim doing
what is in the kit that's a lot of kitty
litter
okay I'll be right there what's going on
[Music]
wow
gross he must have been involved to get
the same treatment as the Morrisons this
isn't the same way Chief Morrison was
killed was about sending a message this
is different look at this it's awesome
they didn't want Stevenson going into
shock wanted him Lucid wanted them to
watch the tape the mirrors they tortured
his wife in front of him and he couldn't
look away this was about getting
information I mean Stevenson wasn't
involved Dawson must have found the hole
in the roof of his truck he knew we were
getting closer to truth oh man she was
pregnant we were all M.I.A so they went
after the next best source so I'm
talking to Roscoe to you to me even
though he was working with them while
they though he was working with us we
let him in maybe we could have protected
these two three
I'm letting you go on the grounds that
you're not up to the test how many more
my men have to be slaughtered before you
accept the job is too big for you you
leave before there's any more stink on
you maybe you can land a paycheck as a
security guard somewhere oh you dick
maybe we can get something off Jasper
when the lab work comes back I've got to
tell Stevenson's parents what happened
at least I can do is look them in the
eye and tell them they've lost their son
and daughter-in-law and grandchild don't
forget the grandchild part go see what
you can find at hubbles I will first
someone asked the last cop in my craved
for lunch
huh way to honor them as you find out he
did it you switch off their lights fake
Stevenson made an enemy of someone he
put in jail too I guess I'll take the
picture officer Baker just ordered our
last piece that's son of a [__]
Morrison Kleiner and Stevenson moral
killed in dramatic ways someone was
trying to send a message this is what
happens when you screw up it didn't go
after you means you're not involved oh I
was in Memphis when Kleiner was murdered
New York when the Stevensons were killed
Alabama the night someone went after
Roscoe and Florida went jobbling and my
brother died my Alibis airtight you can
check for yourself
I already did
if I keep my eyes on Outsiders because
we both know I'm not the only Outsider
in margrave
talking about your buddy Finley he's
someone I'm using to find who killed Joe
this whole thing's about dirty cops and
you're clean and teal didn't become
Chief until after the killing started
Finley's the only one left oh he's
totally playing this guy out 100 yeah he
finds Hubble's phone number in my
brother's shoe then Hubble suddenly
panics and confesses to the murder
sounds like [__] there's got to be a
reason Finley wanted Hubble to go down
for killing Joe
love watching this guy think I'm
breaking into Hubble's house tonight
till I find something that directly
connects I'll build a Finley oh he's so
smart he's totally baiting this guy you
find anything he bring it straight to me
bait back at you you know where I'll be
first thing I was off was like he's the
only one not touched that would make him
the most suspicious right yeah totally
yeah he's got a flatter him yeah and
making the the murder we just saw look
like it was because he was involved
instead of not involved
you need anything else got a new ship in
the deer calls in today not hunting deer
remember one of those blackjacks
grab a gun while you're at it grab three
guns
this discreetly breaking in today in my
Bentley that is not mine I wish Richard
would gain weight throughout this season
not having the time to work out yeah
eating like [__] in Margaret dropping
muscle gaining fat
Terry we just about reached the midpoint
of the Atlantic hurricane keep in mind
oh
oh here we go it's goddamn war zone now
just after noon local time badass
Tom Cruise never put all that [__] on
his face no never
oh my God we can see their faces ah they
don't even care to hide it you're 90 of
the way there boys
oh
do you think they had all these
Venezuelan people here at the same time
or do they keep ordering more
oh nice
no no horn and no horn
[Music]
whoa kill him peace
oh I felt that
little tiny gun a little cute gun yeah
baby's first things you can take down
the big guy with a little gun
hey
yes buddy
Super Duty
nice yeah oh boy freaking kill him kill
him jack
[Laughter]
Woodland Franklin Junction City Union
Western and Zebulon as well as the
greater make and go we were under a
class but now related to a flash yes I
knew it
[Music]
oh
nice look what happens when you try to
use your little gun yeah
oh no crow
come on Jack
whoa that's crazy
oh jeez love a good house fight
wowie you guys are destroying the house
on the pool
no that's his weakness no
leave it done Unbreakable
get in there Finley
oh good awesome dude
Finley put him in his grave Finley come
on man
[Music]
or Rachel could just do the trick sure
yes
all right
this skinny twerk get a one-up on Jack
he's like six times your size man
yeah
floats your way over to there is that
gonna work being all waterlogged yeah
[Music]
damn Jack Reacher Finley where are you
Philly he's counting on you man
oh what a shot that is
yes I know how they're manufacturing
their money the Columbia professor said
it all comes down to the paper and Joe
could never figure out how they were
getting the paper to print their cash
you know what's unique about U.S
banknotes they're made of cotton dollars
are all the same size Bubba was a
skilled currency manager he kept planter
flush with a fresh supply of one dollar
bills from cash intensive industries
that wanted to hide their income from
the governments I think I'm following
singles would be shipped into margrave
from all over the country planner
chemicals must have developed something
to bleach the ink off the money without
harming the paper itself runoff from
this process destroyed Chester
Mississippi oh this makes sense
Jack bleacher counterfeiting operation
you can justify the kill Clinton did
another way animal feed
you know why people use kitty litter to
clean up oil spills it contains
diatomaceous earth it's an absorbent
coagulating agent used in everything
from pesticides to pool filters to
animal feed uh you start ordering
massive amounts of De people get
suspicious but you buy feed when you've
got cows no one looks at you twice so
they're hiding the money in the cows
once the bills were washed they were
dried printed one side and the other
they use the old version of the hundreds
pre-1990s so they don't have to make the
magnetic security strip they use in
today's bills wow truckers then drive
the money down to Florida where it
awaits its final Journey overseas to
Venezuela okay but this is all just
Theory it's a really detailed Theory yep
we need fake cash that we can link
decliner's company you must have had
some cash stashed somewhere at his home
I'm gonna go back and tear the place
apart I'll feel Finland you called me
first I I just wanted to you know
I love you
everything cool better than cool cool I
think creature just busted this whole
thing wide open ah Picard's crooked I
mean I mean I wouldn't put a bath
I hope not meet me at Pete goblings
house we're about to close the lid on
this thing
oh yeah three hitters on how to toward
the motel off this probably to find out
which room I'm in all right doing under
a fake name tell me you didn't park your
car right out front
of course not
turn the TV up loud drop that gun you
have a pocket knife what am I a Boy
Scout grab the bar from the closet wow
smart
ever seen a Kool-Aid commercial oh yeah
oh yeah 300 thanks
I hope they do me yes let's go
what the hell I'm a cop call 9-1-1
damn
oh wow
[Applause]
[Music]
yes my man
I see neighbor says Judy packed up and
left town a couple days ago they're
spooked after what happened at Hubble's
house last night what happened to
Apple's house I killed Dawson Kleiner
and four other guys
so now we've got nothing let me
Brightside as Mr Johnson wasn't here
when they did it she wasn't Mrs Jones
Judy never took Pete's last name look at
how Joe wrote joblin's garage he put the
apostrophe after the S it's her first
name where two joblings reside his
parents house keep telling you finally I
know Details Matter let's go
I mean you're a detective did you know
my boy was dead the last time you were
here yes Ma'am why didn't you tell us
you seem like nice people I didn't have
the heart
oh but it's exactly because you have a
heart we know exactly what we're looking
for boxes just like the one Roscoe and I
saw at his house AC baby
like these
gut the Bucks
God damn take some yeah call Picard tell
him to meet us at The Farmhouse where we
left the Jaguar we've got everything he
needs to take down the Kleiner
foundation and deal at the same time
cards totally getting on it uh
found something on the shooter who
killed that EPA agent Wilkes Picard FBI
agent named nitlo caught the case got a
copy of his ID badge 63 220 pounds
blonde blue eyes like Picard
yep I'd say we're making progress but
you keep talking about nitmo in the past
tense that's because he died of cancer
three years ago but his old part
ner We can question him
space out of the Atlanta field office
guy named Picard how the hell did you
know that [__] you guess just the way he
entered that room wow
gotta go Nui
dang dude whoo
the way into that room at Roscoe I was
like totally crooked
I was like it's got to be one of the
other he's Gotta Die or he's gonna be
crooked not too obvious at that moment
yeah I didn't really know him
he was just too nice too calm
son of a [__] and I said it out loud
everyone remember the day Greg said it
out loud I stopped the way it was shot
it's good visual storytelling you were
an astute viewer
anyway so um something about drugs right
that's what's happening yeah it was all
about shipping drugs everyone to get
high shipping heroin across the border
just fatty bricks damn it Mexico no
oh Venezuela
uh come again
okay
they're all the same he said something
about
some type of Vietnamese dish yeah
let me anyway so the Colombians in
Mexico are shipping heroines that's
right that's right and that whole scene
where Jack tries all the heroin just to
make sure it's real like what a crazy
moment
that was fun that was a fun one we gotta
see Reacher Go full on army boy that was
great or Marine was he Marine Army yeah
which one he is I've never joined the
military and everyone came close uh so I
I honestly forget the differences that's
no excuse I should still know I'm
American yes I should know the
differences
taught us the difference between all of
us plain and clear which ones baby is on
this the no wait baby's water no the
Marines are water that's why it's
confusing is the Navy's not water I
think the Navy kind of has a little bit
everything is because they have people
on the ground because like the seals are
like you know are like soldiers on the
ground
you know like sealed Team Six and all
that stuff like you know they didn't do
anything at Sea to catch Bin Laden or
anything like that I don't think
not that I know of in my I think Bin
Laden was caught on a ferry he was he
was in his private boat and they paddled
out to him with six guys and just
grabbed him
uh his army is the Army Air Force is the
easy way for his
I think he's an army I feel like yeah
let's let's make we have a computer
right in front of us John yeah but but
the screen but the screen you know it's
just it's it's it's easier this way what
branch is it Terry let's see who can get
there first what branch she started
typing away before right Jack Reacher
here I'll give you a handicap all right
army military police Corps yeah second
Lieutenant first lieutenant Captain
major yeah all right cool I thought it
was Army he's an army brat as they say
anyway Jack Reacher Gotta Go full army
man I think the paint too yeah
yeah uh which was an awesome ass scene
you gotta got you gotta have your fun
cliches that you know are coming of for
some reason he's gonna have a little
extended Showdown with the both guy who
was a dick at the funeral yes gotta have
that moment but it was great I thought
the fight scene was really cool I love a
good house fight especially
when they're thrashing about and using
items around to hit each other leading
into the pool on an unusually dark and
stormy night it's very cinematic and
dramatic I love it I thought that was a
really cool sequence
um and uh Finley breaking out that was a
that was a tense moment I was like I
wonder if I was in this situation if I
would have proceeded as confidently with
what am I talking about I know I would
not have proceeded as confidently
no I think you could I would have hit
her under the bed so I would have done
smart and they wouldn't have known you
were there they head right under the bed
yeah I'd hide in the mattress
yeah between that and the box spring
like I hope they don't find me here this
is Lumpy mattress that's all
that's great though and my favorite part
of when he was breaking
yeah
finally was breaking down the wall
the the people next door to him
didn't suspect the thing until he burst
through
I know he's like surrounding and making
holes and yeah yeah yeah but uh yeah
nothing well because they were I
couldn't tell if they were a sleeper if
they were busy you know
but uh I guess a lot of you must hear a
lot of weird things in a shitty Motel
like that you know you just you mind
your own business until it bursts
through your wall
um One time my wife took me to
a motel in Long Beach for this uh great
this great birthday a lot of great cool
things we gotta do gotta go to the
um the
Marine Corps yeah
to join the Marines it's good aqua
Marine uh what's it called you see the
fishes oh we go to an aquarium aquarium
I joined the Marines to see some fishes
I go to the aquarium yes and oh that's
lovely and it was great with the motel
we were staying at Yelp did not prepare
us oh it's the first time walked in
right away Hitman a massive and I've
dealt with cockroaches at old apartments
like we're just like it was a Non-Stop
amount of like little cockroaches or
whatever
huge ass dead cockroach I refuse to pick
it up and throw it away I just refused
to
and I was like I can't I can't touch
that like I can't I can't grab I just
don't want to have the feeling of
texture all through the toilet paper
yeah like I said I can't do it oh yeah
yeah it totally makes my skin crawl so I
ain't crushing anything big underfoot
too went down to management told them
that they had to clean up this dead
cockroach and they were like oh sorry
then they ever will move you to another
motel room and I was like I don't even
consider that as an option I thought you
were just gonna come in there and pick
it up for me
not only do you not have to see the
roads anymore you don't have to see this
whole entire room and then
um later that night couldn't sleep and
then people next door loud and clear as
if there were no walls doing it super
loud awesome
great night sounds like I mean you know
you're you're witness to somebody's Joy
yeah in that moment so yeah it's a motel
experience for you and then I burst
through the wall and said I'm a cop
just to see what they would do then I
went back to bed
[Music]
uh that was fun and if a card's bad and
Neely coming in with the information
rather nick of time to give us the right
amount of information we need
uh yeah man yeah look at the cardio that
was awful [__]
interesting mystery because like it's
it's one of those
it's a complicated mystery it is that's
a lot of information I got to keep up
with so it's got everybody got it
especially Eight dollar bills
all right
it is like and two when you have him
like bending the truth to draw that one
guy out too it's like okay wait I gotta
keep all this in order because because
uh clearly that guy was not implicated
in the greater uh mystery because of how
they tortured and killed him and his
wife but to play it to that guy like he
was is a great idea is that a hammer on
that drama with that Gap huh yeah man
make her pregnant that's awful that's
truly yeah vile it's it's it's and what
a I love I appreciate as much as I can
be like you know I like a good nasty
horror thing I do appreciate in moments
like this where you see something like
that you're like oh this is like
realistic and horrible and we don't need
to see any of it uh except the aftermath
and I already feel all that ickiness you
know and somehow
really funny really really and kind of
erotic you know
very attracted to cannot disagree with
you on that one John just like
hilariously erotic simultaneously rare
to do both yeah Jack Reacher erotic
comedy
okay so here's the bad guy they're all
the bad guy well that's everyone in
Margaret is bad so so his teal the whole
time yeah I mean that's the thing is
like it's an interesting array of of the
mystery and the culprits because it's
like everyone who you did suspect or at
least most of them are involved but also
more people are involved and also it you
know they all are I think it's it's a
nice way to do it because
you don't have to like bend over
backwards to come up with the most
convoluted culprit but also Yeah by
putting I think it's kind of like he
said in the episode by scattering all
this stuff amongst you know all this
other chaff you know you can kind of
hide the forest the trees for the forest
or whatever he says about the fireworks
and when they find the money at the end
so yeah it's like you know you have
these people who I feel like in a lesser
show or in a differently organized show
or if it was just about like oh it's
just one culprit then it would be like
oh well Kleiner being involved like
that's
you know like that could have been
disappointing we're finding out here
that teal is involved or or uh the the
Kleiner kids are involved like those
things could read as underwhelming in a
lesser show because you totally suspect
them and it's not that they're not
involved it's just as you don't know how
and you can't prove it and I think
that's a good way to put us in the shoes
of the the characters trying to crack
the case yeah we're about to have a
prisoner of Azkaban scene yeah
everybody comes in monologue more guns
on more guns so
um
I guess we're in the end game now
they're in the end game we're in the
friend game what's your final
predictions John before before we get to
the episode I think I think Finley lives
Finley lives I think Roscoe also I
changed my Rosco I think she's gonna
live now I think Roscoe has to live and
I think she might help save the day
because I don't know I mean you know you
can account on Picard doing something
but also she's Wily and she's not in the
room yet I think Kristen crook steps in
a Claymore Mine TS definitely sure
and then Paul Hubble comes back at the
very end and reveals it was his plan all
along yeah oh that would be crazy
nobody suspects a pencil pushing
accountant if he wanted to go to prison
yeah yeah he wanted to go into hiding
he wanted to be threatened with his
balls chopped off damn then we could get
to the second season and be on top of
that we can be on time
right there on Amazon Prime whenever it
drops hopefully and unaffected by the
writers
[Laughter]
they say it's I think it's done filming
actually or it's filming it's in
production somehow I can't do any
reshoots nope everyone is like not
concerned like Deadpool 3 it's already
scheduled to still film but they can't
do any rewrites I'm like guys
movies are always being Rewritten like
more than you would ever more than you
would ever suspect and so is TV his
constant rewrites happening for a reason
to improve upon it while you're making
it and to also be like okay this
actually isn't working we need to change
this and now they don't have that option
The Duffer Brothers literally put out a
thing today they were they they went on
the stranger things writer's account and
they were like hey Duffer's here writing
doesn't stop when production starts so
we can't start filming and we hope this
ends soon we hope you understand yeah
yeah you think out of anyone they would
be like the most championing for
stranger things right yeah they're
freaking writers for the [__] yes
exactly yeah this comes down to the
streaming effect of it all but anyway
guys Reacher season two did you predict
everything like how we got everything
right everything that they're hiding the
counterfeit money inside of the cows
totally called it that's right totally
called it that's right and the paper and
the papes yep the paper they got all
that animal feed on the papes
clean that [__] off boy called it I'm
gonna start using kitty litter and then
mopping yeah scrape kitty litter all
over your floor strip everything away
from these varnished panels start fresh
clean the camera lens with the kitty
litter John yeah it doesn't matter what
kind of kitty litter just grab some
kitty litter and dump it on and then we
can make our own counterfeit lens why
would we need to do that I don't know
why not dip the monitors into the kitty
litter
we're out of fresh ones use the used
kitty litter you need a blank monitor
how about a blank lens how about some
blank floorboards
yeah boy oh shout out someone oh
Lex Lex for shouting you out you want to
know why because you're one of the few
who appreciates you're a jack
appreciator
you appreciate yes we try to pull that
[__] off and not many people do and at
our patreon you're the only one who's
part of this reward tier who comments on
our watch alongs on patreon Jack
commentator oh my god dude so Lex I want
to say thank you we are grateful for you
I'm definitely in my mind speaking with
my mouth trying to think of other things
that's in for you the Jack thinker hey
that's right no Jack has a tater here
it's all about Jack thinker so uh thank
you for always being super supportive
Jack supporter yeah and
um I hope that one day you and I can
meet in person and we could talk about
why you wish you were sitting with John
instead Jack meter and I will be like oh
let me take my Jack Cleaver to you Lex
for making me feel bad about my ego Jack
murder
all of these are good and fit the
templates
and I just add Earth don't worry about
that pesky first syllable that would
make a real time
Jack lexer there you go perfect wait
relax are you a woman or a guy you don't
have a avatar and nor a pronoun
identification here either way you're a
fox because that's well if you're a girl
I could say Jack meet her
oh we're not bad at all it's good it's
good and if you're a guy I could say
Jack
[Music]
that's the facts Jack
attack
snack Reacher you know if they should
rename the the Jack Reacher movies too
but Jack
hey
Jack feature one and two that's gonna be
a good good box set to the Jack features
yeah and you're always giving us updates
too on Jack Reacher on the on one on
things we missed and that you love the
soundtrack don't worry John will
serenade you one day I will I'll do it
likes common intersection that's right
yeah Lex is one of uh one of the Die
Hard psychos man
[Laughter]
it works
alrighty Lex much love and I hope you
have a great rest of your week
okay we're good to go now
okay bye
foreign